tu as une étude qui ne devrait pas
redorer le blason de la télé réalité à
présent vous regardez un peu la télé
réalité vous aimez bien plus of moyen
d'accords selon une association
britannique les programmes de terrils et
télé réalité aurait un effet néfaste sur
les jeunes qui du coup serait complexées
par leur physique à cause de ces fameux
candidat de télé réalité un peu silicone
est beau gosse musclé tatati et tatata
c'est bourdin direct vous explique tout
cela
24% des jeunes affirment que la télé
réalité lors d'une des complexes
physiques que c'est une enquête qui a
été menée au royaume uni sur des jeunes
de 18 à 25 ans là-bas en fait y'a un
programme qui s'appelle love island
on y voit en effet des jeunes gens
physique de rêve en maillot de bain les
jeunes adorent c'était l'émission de
télé-réalité qui était la plus regardée
l'an dernier mais sa cause de sérieux
dégâts les jeunes se compare angoisses
des primes certains vont même jusqu'à
avoir des pensées suicidaires
quand même 23 % 23% des jeunes anglais
qui regarde ça qui aurait des pensées
suicidaires c'est quand même dingue
qu'est ce que vous en pensez alors c'est
vrai que bon ils sont tatoués sont
musclés l'envoi une faute au sol et qui
sont sont superbes
avec enfin voilà une image de la femme
en tout cas voilà ben quelques vacances
est discutable
c'était une indiscutable voilà c'est ce
que je cherchais qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mais non mais moi ça me désole
faut juste que les jeunes comprennent
que effectivement la télé c'est pas la
vraie vie les unes de magazines c'est
pas la vraie vie et que la vraie vie
elle est et c'est ça que j'adore dans ce
plateau autour de ce plateau sac peut y
avoir des nanas super bien gaulé comme
caroline ithurbide doit y avoir des
nanas comme moi un peu moins bien gaulée
mais avec avec des gros seins avec des
gros seins trop belle et est ce que je
trouve intéressant c'est que
l'angleterre à chaque fois c'est pas la
première fois qu'ils font une étude
comme ça pour s'inquiéter du bien-être
de leurs jeunes ils le font là sur la
terre ait l'on sait ya quelques mois sur
les réseaux sociaux pour savoir lequel
était le plus compliqué à vivre pour les
jeunes il avait découvert que les
effectivement instagram était nocif au
bien-être des jeunes du coup ils ont
essayé de mener une campagne et je
trouve qu'on devrait un petit peu
prendre exemple sur eux au moins là
dessus parce qu'ils essayent de prendre
prendre un peu soin des jeunes qui sont
qui sont un peu déprimé alors qu'une
surtout que c'est une période de la vie
où effectivement on se cherche on se
on n'est pas forcément sûr de soi qu'est
ce que vous en pensez c'est assez moi je
suis un peu surpris parce que quelque
part je trouve que la télé fait bien son
boulot parce que la plupart du temps
elle nous montre une télé réalité avec
des gens qui sont extrêmement bien foutu
très beau etc mais qui parallèlement à
sa sont très très bête
il ya une compensation alors qu'il ya
des gens beaux et intelligents comme
thibault qui est au centre de la photo
d'ailleurs thibault qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous je ne suis pas à droite
déjà sur la photo non mais je crois
surtout que rien n'a changé en fait un
ennemi la faute sur les réseaux sociaux
sur la tnt aujourd'hui sauf que avant je
regardais olive et tom j'étais complexée
du niveau de foot de l'hiver vous laisse
regarder
d'autant que de tout bien sûr tant les
ados se sont comparés dans les années 90
je regardais alerte à malibu je pensais
que pamela anderson serait ma femme est
donc ça va n'a pas de sap a chargé un
vous continuez à la dent jours bon bah
voilà donc je suis déformé à cause de la
télé donc pourquoi plus maintenant
qu'avant je ne crois pas c'est juste
qu'il faut prendre conscience faire
prendre conscience à tout le monde
non ce n'est pas la réalité vous a posé
la question à la télé réalité donne des
complexes aux jeunes est ce que vous
construisez vous ne comprenez pas et
vous comprenez à 72% visiblement ces
impacts quand même pas ce que ça donne
une image globale de ce qu'est la
jeunesse labeouf en tout cas ce qu'on
imagine est là la beauté et donc pour
28% d'entre vous vous arrivez à tenir à
distance cette image là